this week we've got floor seats semen
injection and salt Bay sued when I talk
about that one yet nasi yaar was a mu C
Pat this was his name what's the first
one for the first story there was a
family that was forced to sit on the
floor of an airplane I heard about this
why were they being disruptive no they
were that's to their seat and they just
didn't exist the seats just weren't
there they weren't there like they took
out the seats
unblocked that's illegal like these sold
seats that they never had so it says 37
J there's no 30 tell you the number it
was 41 de and s so they had he just
didn't your seats
whoa Billy went up to 40 probably or
were there just spaces where the seats
used to be I'm not sure because I can't
see the floor in the photos I know what
they happen what they happen yo they
probably sold tickets for like a 747
plane but they got a mixed up in all
that a 737 so the seating only went up
to like 40 yeah this about what's the
plan that was selling tickets for like a
tribe of the airline did say that it was
the last minute airplane change see then
they should just oh my god case closed a
liability here can analyze them on the
floor exactly and it's actually against
the rules
yeah I mean who suggested that right
even when they're landing all your stuff
goes flying out didn't even let you put
[ __ ] like on the floor yeah underneath
the seat that's crazy
yep so they did allow the family to sit
in those like pull down the flight
attendant wanted jump seat sir yeah but
then they these are uncomfortable they
ask them if they can move because they
had to get the drink service started and
all that stuff over there sit down on
the floors this is the family why did
they just wait for the next flight
that's the family well because they
already pay for it yeah Aaron's fall off
what do you mean why would they have to
wait for the next line because the
airline [ __ ] up but there's no chairs
yeah but that sucks
or they should be reimbursed or
something to find a difference right
like when they go would you be willing
to wait for a later flight for $400 yeah
so so that's what exactly I'm saying if
there's no chairs what you weren't you
weren't forced to stay in the flight
well yeah and even if it was their fault
or their mistake you can still wait for
the next flight yeah but they didn't
want to they mean so if they didn't want
to then that was the family's choice to
sit on the floor or something right so
it but then it's a mistake right and in
they happen so from that point on you
can't play victim if it's your choice to
stay there I see what you're saying
right because the sensible thing that a
human being would do would be like I'll
get the next exactly I mean the double
voucher you know a thousand bucks right
yeah yeah because instead of saying oh
I'll just sit on the floor and to be
honest with you I'm not defending that
airline I would love to sit on the
[ __ ] floor because you could spread
your [ __ ] legs out you slammed into
the scene yeah it was so uncomfortable
I don't you get it slammed to this they
slow down or like it's not like that
when they land yeah it is Oh and when
they lens gonna hurt your ass for sure
you're gonna fly somewhere you'll get on
those chairs that like fold yeah it's
still the commercial you're not enough
fighter jet you know I mean what it's
still a commercial flight but haven't
you seen like an international flight
like the old Asian ladies like just
sitting cross-legged in the back and
like chillin or like doing yoga and [ __ ]
that's not that bad yeah cuz that makes
me - I'll be stretching the back yeah
yeah International that's the plane
plane is a lot bigger
oh so it's more stable yeah I skates on
and there's an international place when
it lands I could barely feel it yeah but
the the smaller ones like the local but
not local what you call domestic ones
you could feel that [ __ ] especially the
ones only like two seats on each side or
when the [ __ ] pilot sucks ass it's
like the difference between a like a
cruise crispy both the little baby boy
the propeller ones have you been on what
we had to do that in Costa Rica yeah the
smaller the plane the crazier it feels
yeah I've been on those for skydiving
they take you in those tiny little one
oh it really smooth smooth and it was
like they used them as taxis in Costa
Rica to get from different places on the
country it's pretty cool yeah it was a
lot less scary once we were in it then I
wanted ride one of those duck planes
yeah I want to try them so cool doesn't
that happen when you go to Fiji I don't
know maybe yeah yeah let me go on a duck
plane to go into that [ __ ] or something
like that
dan and Clara went to the Maldives for
the honeymoon he told me that [ __ ] you
know they're sinking we gotta go then
the Maldives are sink I heard that's
just a [ __ ] though to get there I don't
want to be a full day it's like three
different flights it's like a tiny ass
little plane to another tiny little
plane I'm straight well what if my son
whatever planet we're like you go to
Hawaii stay there for a day or two and
then you go to like Thailand and then
you go to that VMAs yeah then you spend
some time until you get there after you
spread it out a bit but yeah we need a
solid month you go straight there
because the whole day rich people do
that's great to Thailand that's a long
flight
oh yeah that's so long if you were gonna
do that maybe you go like Thailand
Singapore Bali like that in the same
area yeah we did a trip from Australia
to Malaysia and I thought it was gonna
be a quick flight cuz it's like there
somewhere seven hours it was still
freaking long yeah yeah so with this
family here they complained once they
arrived to their destination and they
were given thirty British pounds oh
that's ridiculous gesture so then they
ended up contacting this program that's
called ripoff Britain and they told this
program the entire mm-hmm situation and
then finally they contacted the airline
which is called tu I and they were able
to give the family any full 1,300
British pound refund
oh nice but after all that so they
didn't even bother to do fix the
situation like did the guys go well I
don't know where your seats are they
might have different policies than
Airlines in America well no they did say
that it is not like never allowed to let
someone exactly can't believe they let
so it almost sounds like the the the
flight attendant told them well you
could sit on the floor mm-hmm guess we
will yeah I know like that's this is all
kinds of [ __ ] up yeah
Alliance for letting that happen this
also shows you don't really have to sit
in a chair to be safe that's what I
really show dance belt imma say no no
cuz like you know what they always tell
you these things like oh you can't write
on the back of a truck bed I'm like you
know how many truck beds I fit in the
back of its perfectly awesome ever since
I saw a Rambo riding in a cargo plane
with a bunch of chickens and pigs and
[ __ ] I said you don't need to have
seatbelts on a plane should run the
world involved
I saw Rambo he did it I could do it once
a country has bumpkins over here dude
Bry next story this man in Ireland he
was self administering doses of his own
semen so he were himself oh my god he
was eating his eating objectives acting
his own semen secure his back pain wait
why it wasn't work did he read that that
was that there was nothing written ever
of this beauty mix it up with like stem
cells oh that could be what everything
he thought it was is the 33 year old man
Oh God so he has a history of chronic
lower back pain he smoked some weed down
like to inspect yourself with their own
semen stretch maybe what research you
read about come therapy there have been
reports of subcutaneous semen injection
into rats and rabbits but it's never
been done on human and those rabbits
have really nice backs now I don't know
exactly what they use it for the rabbits
are like my back feels nice how do you
know the [ __ ] was gonna target the back I
think he did mix it up with maybe he was
trying to make a comeback
you know maybe she has to find one come
back later nice
yeah so she was injecting himself with a
monthly dose of some monthly for 18
consecutive months using a hypodermic
needle he bought online has it been
working this particular occasion that
led him to the hospital he gave himself
three doses of C you think he like got
boners from it like he just like those
his kink like maybe he's just like no
it's for my back what happened
like did he get hurt her yes actually
the semen was leaked into soft tissues
and so he was given intravenous
antimicrobial treatment that's what
happened in the hospital I don't know
exactly what it was that made him go oh
[ __ ] I need to go to the hospital I was
if I was a physician and I asked you so
what's going on with your back
I've been putting [ __ ] in my back okay
really dude I take this needle I come
into a petri dish and nice okay and I do
this that wouldn't kill him on sight you
laugh he turns around and he shows you
and you see the hole and you press it
and I would be so [ __ ] mad I'd be
like who told you this oh he looks at me
dead in the eye he goes stem cells baby
yeah yeah you know semen cells and you
know how they come acts like you know
when it goes into the body it's just
looking for the ol Reese so it's just
swimming like a [ __ ] trying to
infiltrate super sperm
they got no like this is the lower back
this is the [ __ ] you got a million but
hair sites just crawling up in your
blood vessel trying to [ __ ]
infiltrate something oh well I don't
know what country the ones that dies
immediately when it touches blood man
I'm trying to get yeah stem cells in my
body right now I would be nervous say
you know how like if an air bubble goes
into your vein then you die yeah like
what if he acts come come come in his
vein like what if that happen
he has a good antimicrobial treatment oh
my god that's just so crazy
it's so weird they did mention too that
he left the hospital without draining
the wound
yeah doctor was probably like now I'm
good I probably would have let them he
goes well we're gonna drink no it's a
little wet stain on the back of it we're
all clean the bleach off your shirt
first what's that smell do yeah yeah it
comes smells better absolutely I mean
especially if the personally been
drinking rock stars
I know rock star cover what gets people
to think this doctor don't know [ __ ] I'm
gonna come on myself next yeah let's go
next where does he buy his finished
undershirts always I know they look so
comfy yeah yeah you guys forgot what he
looks like
the sheerest not one wrinkle dude he
boxes too which is kind of cool he's
actually really good I was like holy
she's actually really good I think you
look amateur boss or something damn
choppa looks like he does art a lot
naked with the glasses on only oh I feel
like I've seen so many parodies that I
forgot what he looked like he looks like
he [ __ ] with those sunglasses and socks
on and sunglasses because he's like this
Oh like Musiq Soulchild oh yeah I was so
dude he's so [ __ ] dope and then when
I saw his cross Howard Oh Jermaine Dupri
too right really no I mean maybe I'm it
just looks kind of faded a little he has
a lazy eye like a [ __ ] dude that's
the best move his team could have made
for him so when I saw that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] mean all this sounds terrible
off-key that's how I felt when Ryan
Gosling singing in la-la-land cuz it's
like Oh Ryan Gosling he's so mysterious
and then he started saying and I was
like off-key by like half a key or some
[ __ ]
he was like brooding in silence and he
was like says the right thing only the
right thing and otherwise he's he's
comfortable with the silence he's the
highest-paid actor to never say anything
anything oh no I don't know if I could
tell keys because I thought Ryan was
pretty good was it the type of music am
i doing the music I don't know what it
was but I did not enjoy it but I also
found out in my 23andme I'm 50% off on
pitches it tells you like how what is
that word like what you kill in death
that toned up there's another word they
use but it's like if you have like
perfect picture oh yeah yeah I'm 50%
chance I don't have it not always
accurate it sounds like I would taste
the elantra soap and I don't what the
motive that's why it's always chances
it's always probably because it's
whatever alleles are expressed yeah but
mine is 50% chance I can't sing but you
can hear it I just like Ryan Gosling
when he was like more quiet just like
that branding like when you get to know
someone too much and you thought they
were hot and then they like become a
human being and you're like I don't want
to see your flaws alright so salt babe
he is being sued from like his ex
staffers because they are claiming that
he would swipe tips from them and then
fired them for complaining damn he's
smooth criminal I've heard a lot of bad
reviews about his restaurant though is
it his restaurant it could be a lot of
haters too well it's not it's like it
like if you read them like they it's
like people who really wanted to like
the place because they love salt based
so much no they're not haters they're
his fans and so uh because prices are
[ __ ] ridiculous like the cheapest
thing on his [ __ ] is like a burger and
the burger is like it's like like 20 or
30 bucks or some [ __ ] like that but is
it is this a restaurant in Dubai
I mean it's multiple restaurants oh okay
there's maybe his main main the one
we're talking about here is in Manhattan
yeah so the V fly around the world just
to [ __ ] do his I'm sure let me [ __ ]
the beef yeah does he do that yeah okay
does the beef quality looks amazing yeah
when I seen the video marbling and all
this stuff oh yeah that beef looks good
but then I saw the prices it's
ridiculous I'm so scared when you have
the knife oh yeah you got scales dawg I
know but he makes me like I feel like
he's a butcher like what we're saying
that they didn't like
prices or they just saying idea like the
food it was both uh it was like the food
was very whatever which you know it's
it's steak you can make it at your
[ __ ] house mhm and then on top of
that the prices were ridiculous weights
ridiculous the price is ridiculous
there's nothing best cheap on there
there's no way that a burger should be
like 30 bucks unless it's like a 5 wag
you on it and even then it'd be like 100
or something but that's not what he's
serving I read the reviews and I was
like Oh makes sense cuz it seems there
are stuff that they do like on it but
they're saying like what you get for
what you pay is I hear in here you know
so if you're if you're walking away with
a $600 bill mm-hmm right for a steak and
like two sides or like a 500 or whatever
it's still ridiculous
that's expense have you been to a hos
tacos yeah Trejo the vegan that was
really good no offensive for me too I'm
like a 6 by 4 I can't pay 6 bucks for
taco they're supposed to be like the
new-age
gourmet really good I'm too cheap too
expensive
I like you're alone huh you know people
have that argument right there's like
well why can't it be fancy it's not that
is that arguably to like if you have a
street taco and that right the way you
made bets is the same way that they made
the street taco the masa was made you
know and you did it by hand you're using
the same meat using the same meat but
yours looks prettier so why should I pay
more for yeah well the tray hosts tacos
they use all organic ingredients like
that yeah it's like a clean eating
version of street food falseface don't
even like organic a lot of like
restaurants try to elevate Vietnamese
food right but they're not listen need
to be elevated they're not doing
anything new to it it's like it's the
same [ __ ] hmm you know like you're not
doing anything new show me something new
yeah so unless you're gonna show me
something new instead of saying that oh
it's elevated because I changed the
setting mm-hmm then I'm not gonna pay
[ __ ] $18.00 for your baller [ __ ] yeah
sure show me what you that's different
types of clientele because some people
just go pay for the restaurant
experience yeah yeah buddy sandwich it's
this place in DTLA indeed you know the
food's good right you kill a goddamn you
Cole oh is that what's called it is what
is called PLA you just say downtown yeah
so that plays like I write detail like
20 bucks right and I thought it was
gonna be some next-level [ __ ] but it was
one of the most basic bunny sandwiches
I've ever had
and I paid $20 for it Wow because they
said oh it's made with pork belly I was
like you can get a regular pork belly
one for [ __ ] four dollars so what did
I just pay for I think that's like Les
Roches in the kitchen
it's thievery I mean there's less flavor
that's what I don't like it's like you
better show me something dope I see you
well it just depends on what you value
like she was it mm-hmm
like for example like I think there's a
lot of American food that does that
really well so you have your regular mac
and cheese that you have but then
there's other mac and cheese where they
put truffles in yeah they put like very
aged cheese right they throw like Maine
lobster so I understand like the cost of
goods to create expensive versus these
other places were it's the same exactly
I'm sorry it has to make sense that you
can't fool us like we're [ __ ] Asian
yes like we don't I do I do like
trailers tacos oh it was pretty yeah I
wouldn't call it street tacos oh I think
that's the difference here is that
there's already something that exists
yes so it's difficult for people to get
around something new right and palate
that and pay more what I thought it was
like a healthier version of Street food
because I personally got stomachaches
from eating Street feel like I just have
a really sensitive something supposed to
get those didn't give me heartburn so I
was like oh it's high tea it's an option
that doesn't give me heartburn that's
another thing too it looks like it's
gonna be like really nasty and greasy
and like heavy and then you eat it and
you're like oh it's pretty clean yeah
because we get the tacos next to our
brother's house mm-hmm and every time I
eat it I'm always like [ __ ] I'm gonna
have diarrhea later and I do but when I
do you're really selling it I'm also
like yes I got the full experience
I don't like pay nothing my bajo you
need it to learn specifically the red
sauce if I eat just the green sauce I'd
be fine
but some meats beg for the red sauce I
was on your side now I'm on the trail
trails tacos
[Music]
you